someone go ahead and tell me about x
studies you can pretty much just read it
off right
minus minus 6
a and then my cos turns into sine
you happy with that okay
you need a bit of space here okay i've
got a displacement equation
i've got a velocity equation and i can
say because i defined my certain moment
as t equals zero i can go to both of
these and make
a substitution right let's go ahead and
do that so at
t equals zero i can say
i know what the position is i know what
the velocity is
so going to here i can say uh let's see
here
a cos of i'm substituting t equals zero
right so i just get a cos
alpha the the six t is gone so a cos
alpha equals
this is the displacement equation so
it's three you care with that
similarly looking at this next equation
down here
i can say negative 6
a sine of what
60 percent but again i'm doing this t
equals zero business so it's it's alpha
again isn't it what's that equal to
negative 24. and i got that from
this piece of information here okay
excuse me now this is really great this
is really nice i substituted in t
equals zero so that's why it's gone i
have two unknowns a
and alpha and i have two equations so
this is just i've turned all the simple
harmonic motion business
into something you could have done back
in year nine this is a simple
simultaneous equation set up
i could do one more thing just to make
it even lazier for me right before i
label these one and two
i will label this one but before i call
this one two what would you like me to
do to make it easier to work with
i can i can simplify how am i going to
simplify
yeah i'm going to divide both sides
through by negative 6. that okay
so that gives me this a sine alpha
equals
4. you happy with that i'm calling this
one
equation 2. now we're used to
like systems of linear equations you're
like oh i can substitute
i can uh what's it called i can
eliminate right having a look at these
two
think for a moment i need to get rid of
either alpha
or a which do you think is easier to get
rid of
you reckon you want to get rid of a what
would you do to get rid of a
you could divide through you could go
say 2
divided by 1 and that your a's would
cancel
and then you would get 10 alpha on the
left hand side wouldn't you and then you
would get
four on three on the right hand side
don't get that right
yeah now i i'm totally okay with that
yeah
hmm interesting suggestion angered just
in case you didn't catch that right
um and get's thinking about using
auxiliary angle right i can
i can put these two together i've got a
sum of two different
sine functions sorry wave functions and
therefore
i can consider them as a single one with
a shift right i could do that
but you know how i'm always like looking
for lazier simpler ways to do it okay
as i pointed out this is a question
where oops wrong color
this is a question where we can make
choices and i'm going to suggest to you
just
go ahead and do that see how it goes i'm
pretty confident you'll come up with a
good answer
i i'm also reasonably confident you'll
take a
while to get there because the auxiliary
angle is a reason why there's it's an
extension one
technique um you have a sine alpha
is four and you make it into a right
angle triangle oh i see i see
alpha and you have four three yeah yeah
yeah okay so
i could just go all right so i'm gonna
hit pause on you there right
in order to do this i actually kind of
need both of these triangles
i need both of these together right this
is actually i can do this all in one
fell swoop without an indigestion
diagram you know you guys know how much
i love a good diagram
right i love a good diagram when it
helps me do something more efficiently
i think in this case there's even a
simpler algebraic way
to go and just get this without even i
don't even need to divide
what do you think you should equation 1
squared plus equation
now you can totally do either of these
paths
right and like i said like i promised
right when you have genuine choices you
will still get the same
answer out i wonder if anyone can see
why this is such a helpful thing
to do and why to avoid some of the
problems that we can create if we start
say for example solving for alpha
first what do we get out of this right
can someone tell me what i get when i do
this
i'm going to get a squared cos squared
that's that's this one squared plus a
squared sine squared
right there's my left hand side from 1
squared plus 2 squared and then on the
right hand side i get
nine plus 16 which is 25. it's almost
like this question was crafted to do
this
right and this is probably why your
brain started going oh right angle
triangles right because i can see a
triad here
the reason why this is helpful is once
you factor out your cos squared plus
sine squared which is equal to
1 you're getting a squared equals 25
and here while we normally are solving a
quadratic and we have to think of two
values here right i can actually specify
one of them because why what is a
it's an amplitude right it's an
amplitude and i've specified what it is
over here
so i can say i'm only taking a positive
value because
an amplitude is scalar does that make
sense now from here i still do have to
deal
with alpha and you can go to either of
these spots here either equation one or
equation two
i'm not going to completely escape this
problem that i was trying to get away
from right
uh i'm going to go to which one i'll go
to let's go back to equation one
sub a into
one so i'm going to get here if this is
five
cos alpha equals three fifths are you
okay with that
and it's not an exact value because the
three four five triangle doesn't give us
nice angles but it gives us an angle we
can work with none
the less can someone give me it in
radians
please i asked you to get your
calculators out what do you get
9273 would do it for me
dot dot dot okay now 0.9273
that's less than 1.57 that's an acute
angle that your calculator just handed
to you
are you sure it's an acute angle
like is there anything that tells you
that has to be acute
could it not be obtuse or reflex
because like there's an infinite series
of solutions to this right anyone you
want to give me some takes yeah
because
so xiao is going to hear right he's
saying
alpha is what we define as our phase
it's
how far off we are from just starting it
like at a regular
like you know cos function we have to
like shift across because we've already
decided we didn't start at an extremity
of motion
extreme motion that's a good suggestion
however i should point out uh
does it have to be like is there
anything that i said here i'd like it to
be
it is actually the reason why i chose
this in the first place right
but there's actually another piece of
information it's on the board right now
that tells me why alpha ought to be
acute in this particular situation
morgan um
i was doing it because i didn't use
cos i used alpha but yep you divided
through yeah
because we got two equations both
equation nice and positive
if you're using 10 that represents of
course alpha and sine alpha
is positive which means have to be first
quadrant same
for this case because we have to use the
equations okay so
our alpha has to be in the first
quadrant okay
well done morgan so let's think about
this for a second right and this is not
my um
it's not my favorite way of doing it but
i'll just grab on to the language that
you use
each of your two equations here that
you've started solving simultaneously
they give you information about where
alpha has to be right
when you have a look at this first one
here cos alpha equals
three-fifths that's what i get from that
so therefore which quadrants can i
possibly be in
first and fourth
when you look at this second equation
here again i can substitute a in i get
sine alpha equals
four fifths still positive so which
quadrants could you possibly be in
first and second but you have to solve
these simultaneously
right it's got to be the same alpha that
works for both of these so therefore you
can actually exclude
these two because they don't work for
the other one does that make sense
so this is why i have alpha being acute
i'm just going back to jour's point
right
this actually is the reason why i wanted
this have a think about this for a
moment right
i'm starting above and i'm coming back
towards the origin right
so when i'm thinking about should i
choose sign should i choose cos
i truly can think of either but isn't
cause kind of closer to what
i want i don't have to shift it quite so
dramatically i don't have to introduce
such a massive phase shift does this
make sense
it still works it's just that you don't
always get an acute angle down here
i've got a i've got alpha
we already got n right do i have a whole
equation of motion
i do right so i can close this off this
is part a okay
i can say back to here x equals let's
put it put everything together
x equals five i think i said cos right
uh six t plus
zero point nine two seven three et
cetera i suppose this should be an
approximately equals two but you get the
idea
like so okay i probably should say
because we just had the conversation but
i didn't include it in my working
the reason why i've got alpha being
acute here is
alpha acute from
one and two like so
is that right that's where i actually
appealed to to know that it had to be
between
naught and pi on two let me
pause there we have a part b to deal
with okay do you reckon you have enough
steam in you
to take this equation of motion we just
determined together and work out the
next
what's the question the next time that
we come back to this same
displacement here reckon you do that can
i give you a few minutes to have a play
they're not going to come back show you
a solution and also show you what
happens
if you don't choose cos from the
beginning if you've got an answer call
me over and i'll give you a suggestion